yeah but that picture of mark though i'm
trying to find the one
i don't know what you're talking about
what should i search mark's frapp
no dude the one that went viral this
week of him on the surfboard
oh that picture yeah i just you know
it's like ceo tech ceo things
oh got it just yet no mount just
drinking a big weird frappe
mark zuck uh riding this big weird
surfboard
yeah what the [ __ ] is that why does this
surfboard have like a controller
everyone that's the biggest problem with
this with this going viral is everyone
was like oh my god this sunscreen
what is he riding yeah how would how are
people not more freaked out by this
electric surfboard i've never seen this
in my entire life
what the [ __ ] is like a boosted board
for water yeah this dude has a
controller for his goddamn
that's actually the ps6
it's a console and a surfboard
that controller is crazy you can
definitely put that in somebody
oh yeah yeah [ __ ] 12 that's the first
thing i go to
yeah it doubles as a dildo for sure i
mean look at it
the shape of that thing is wild yeah
this is some
science fiction [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is he
writing
where is he where is he on mars
[Laughter]
what sport is this dude i hate that this
picture is
is it enjoyable yeah i hate that he wore
a sweater to like perfectly color
palette this whole image
like his sweater goes with the ocean
like everything about this
just it's just too perfect
and he is caked on he's what
he's caked on with the sunscreen like i
imagine his sunscreen is just like a
like a bowl
and he just his face in it it's like you
know it's like whipped cream texture
he just wipes away on the eyes and mouth
and nose
okay i'm ready to go surfboarding here's
the thing is that
like guys do this they'll put zinc all
over their face because they're in the
water for three four hours
surfing and like no
sunscreen is that water resistant so
they'll just kick their face with
with zinc right but thinking about him
doing this for four hours
doing this boosted board this water
boosted board you get sick of that in
like 10 minutes
it's like a jet ski you're on it for a
little bit and then you're like okay the
novelty is
worn off oh yeah no but for hours yeah
just
where are you going dude
in that same position too
he's uh he's he's got the sunscreen
caked on but he's also got
his cake on oh yeah there are some
people looking at this upset because
they're in the gym squatting every day
and they still can't get an ass like
this
zuck was just born with this [ __ ]
the [ __ ] he's wearing a hoodie because
dude it gets cold
going at [ __ ] 80 miles an hour in the
water
his his boosted board is faster than a
jet ski
this [ __ ] is crazy exactly yeah i think
i think he goes between the beach and
his private island that's got to be what
it's
like you know yeah yeah he's somewhere
very remote
which which then brings the question to
like who took this picture
what kind of paparazzi is there
paparazzi pulls up also on one of these
things that's why zuck is looking so
strange she's like where did you get
yours
these are these are still in beta he
sounds like bonzi buddy
where did you get your surfboard
how do you also have one of those
please enter your first name and your
last name into this
pervert
i am reading your mind why you sound
exactly like him
yo how do how do you how do you do that
you just gotta you know you gotta you
gotta squeeze it down
it sounds like you're talking but
inhaling
how do you do yo
i had a homie who could do that [ __ ] it
was the funniest
[ __ ]
i wish i could do that [ __ ] man he would
do this crazy ass voice
and it would just be a [ __ ] kill me
man
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] man yeah you just gotta you
just gotta clamp it down
hear me where did you get your surfboard
bruh
you